Julius and Ella be living in the same  house Julius is the head of the family  25 so if you notice over here  birthplace hungry mm-hmm is this one of  their other sons I think so yeah  so Julius is married to Ella she's born  in Maryland parents born Russia speaking  Yiddish if her parents were from Russia  they're speaking Yiddish we should jr.  yes uh-huh  during this time period it was more  typical for people to marry within their  same religious background right so  Ella's Jewish  so maybe Julius is Julia Julia so is  Morris and I'm the family Wow I've never  heard of this before my family that's  kind of a big deal to not know about  yeah that sort of changes everything  [Music]